when you say that passion is the
ingredient that most matters and success
I agree but here's how I think about it
without passion nobody if Tony Hawk
didn't wasn't passionate about
skateboarding if I wasn't passionate
about becoming one of the great
entrepreneurs of a generation if LeBron
wasn't passionate about basketball they
wouldn't have put in I wouldn't have put
in the hours the work when you're when
it all makes no sense when it's 10:30 at
night tonight and I've got to go to one
more meeting but I gotta wake up at 5:30
and you know if I didn't have the
passion for the game I wouldn't do it
I would cancel it I wouldn't have booked
it in the first place and so it becomes
the gateway drug religion that allows
you to do the tactical things I have a
vision to where we're going in the
future
I come up with stuff every day that very
few people are thinking about and then
in parallel and it's one of the biggest
reasons I still have a personal brand I
use Instagram and snapchat and Facebook
and Twitter every single day I'm a
practitioner I get my hands dirty I'm
the architect and the Mason